you qu'est ce que c'est que ça
aujourd'hui je devais pas faire de
vidéos et puis là y'a 30 et je me suis
dit [ __ ] j'ai envie de me battre
contre mes abonnés non pas avec les
points mais avec la bouche et revers
aujourd'hui je vous affrontez en
chantant ses parties première chanson my
heart will go on de céline dion parce
que c'est une très belle chanson easy ou
hard
bon on va se mettre les petites vocal qu
à main il faut quand même que je twitte
le lien sinon je vais chanter tout seul
et il ya vidéo perdre un peu de son sang
ce qui sera la meilleure
céline dion à ces petits moments on
attend moi je propose un numéro exclusif
de stylo à la main il ya trop de
concurrence là bas je veux pas être la
plus belle céline dion c'est pas
possible
voilà comme ça quoi qu'il arrive sur la
plus belle 3 et 4 et rina et émail ave
comics au 103e et ouais
la bataille des deux thomas ça je vous
voyais pas mal non
c'est pouvoir telle union jiwa le play
il s'est créé dans la lane du siècle
quoi une lan sur carrick est parti trop
d'émotions merci à vous chers abonnés de
marc chanter avec moi on est cinquième
sur 90 mais y avait 85 personnes qui
chantaient pas donc on est dernier
qu'est ce qu'on va faire cette fois
comme chanson en chanson où je donne
tout ce que j'ai c'est radioactives qui
sera le plus radioactif
oui le pierre début de production de
chasse on est mort
attention là quand le bit part j'adore
ça 1 on a un petit compteur un homme
boudry
c'est la méthode cette femme est décédée
africaine oua à moitié welcome to the
new et de news
j'adore ça rwasa qui fait de la flûte le
fauga l'aise aux abois est que nos
rétines au max evans a dit oui à temps
il ya des cheveux yana ya tout m'attire
de la planète quoi sur ce casque 5e
assez nul à temps mais juan tôt il a dit
la tunique est quoi s'amuser 775 points
mais mec la mêlée lui il reste parce
qu'il avait une chaussette plus
d'entrées que la mienne quoi juste voilé
de la mienne tu sais qu'un problème quoi
pourquoi tenez ça
bientôt je t'interdis la prochaine
chanson qui sera le plus gros au renard
pitié l'autre jour pas pitié pitié pitié
non droit où tout est là les beaucoup
trop fort pour nous quoi cet homme est
maintenant et prend le bruit des animaux
avec squeeze je suis dépressive
les chiens pour vous des chapeaux main
les oiseaux font et les souris force
queen à dieu et aux hommes
pas de faute c'est papa ciao il faut que
ça cesse
c'est idiot grave au droit au retour
mais qu'est ce qui était arrivé mais tu
dit complètement fait d'être honnête je
suis déçu voilà pour la peine tu viens
plus un petit peu le mec qui veut
absolument pas trottoirs et quoi petit
gagnent ou qu'ils perdent tout pareil
j'aimerais bien gagner un jour georges
chakra là près de moi comme témoin comme
ça toi new look a très souvent ni les
bandits et dukic divine de moulins et
oui non
le monde est que oui mais moi le premier
alors on est combien thiem you 19e nay
émergents je pense que le site il avoue
d'ailleurs il est premier mieux regarder
le regarder le risque est ce qu il a une
tête de shakira non pas voir clip non
seulement les joueurs rien
et voilà la fin de cette vidéo sur
karaoké partie on peut dire qu'il 98%
d'entre vous chante mieux que moi en
tout cas j'espère 16h en plus c'est
qu'elle n'était pas aimé la vidéo ça
fera vraiment plaisir n'hésitez pas à le
dire dans les commentaires si vous
voulez d'autres épisodes vous afro sur
karaoké partie c'était un délai un peu
spécial louis ont pris 10 rebonds mais
voilà tous les jours je me sens un petit
peu shakira ya une certaine part de
chacun en moi même et je pense au total
dans une nouvelle vidéo chat au monde